good morning everyone welcome to The
Hangover slot I promise I'll go easy on
all of you my name is Suze Hinton you
can follow me on Twitter and github at
new cat if you want to know what my
username means you can come and find me
after this I'm a front-end developer at
Kickstarter in New York City which we'll
be talking about a little later on I'm
also a member of the node.js Hardware
working group so really enjoyed Rachel's
talk yesterday she was talking about the
no BOTS community so we're both part of
that ok we both also like cuts a lot
which you'll also find out with this
talk I'm recently a member of the newly
minted amber accessibility project
community team should we work on trying
to bring better accessibility to the mas
front-end framework so again talk to me
if you'd like to know more about that
we're actively working on that so why
are we here you're probably reading the
abstract and wondering about that we're
going to try and keep things in mystery
for a little bit longer but the main
points are that today we're talking
about Dada and art and how they can fit
together we're also talking about making
a mess I think it's really important to
make a mess and I'll touch on that a
little later on - there's also a lot of
feelings so if anyone's seen my talks
before you know that this is coming but
I thought I would have a warning that
there are a lot of feelings in this but
it's a good thing to story time I want
to tell you a little story in 1994 I was
9 years old and I was reading the
following book this was my introduction
to programming and you're thinking 1994
pretty strongly Windows 95 is about to
come out but this was my computer so I
was really really excited to learn how
to make art on the computer I'd been
drawing like my entire life and I never
really got that great at it but as a kid
that's all I wanted to do with computers
was I didn't want to type on them I
wanted to make art so I was reading this
book and this was my introduction to
programming and so I guess you could
call that you could call me the littlest
artist at the time but of course I did
grow up and I still was in love with the
idea of sort of the primitive
things that go on behind graphics and so
recently I wrote a library called Olli
DJ s and its job is to put pitches on
this primitive screen so you can kind of
see how that influence is still carried
through I'm not going to tell you how
many years later and give away my age so
I think of myself as the accidental
programa I didn't realize I was going to
be a professional programmer when I was
nine years old I was just having a lot
of fun and so in my personal time I
still like to emphasize on that which is
why I call myself the accidental
programmer I don't care about whether
you use semicolons in your code or not
it just it doesn't matter to me that's
not what excites me about programming so
now I'm going to tell you a story within
a story I had a good friend Lindsay
Smith give me this book and he said to
me I think you'll really like it and I
think this was about seven or eight
years ago so for those who haven't read
it it's called contact by Carl Sagan by
this lovely gentleman here and the main
character is a scientist called dr.
Ellie Arroway and she works for the SETI
movement trying to find extraterrestrial
life so she heads up the program at what
if the astronomy towers and so her job
is to scan all of the signals in the sky
and figure out whether or not that's an
extraterrestrial signal she has to dig
within the noise and try and find that
signal in there and she actually does
one day and her team finds a message
from outer space and so this ends up
taking her to New York City where she
has to attend a lot of like really big
meetings with the government and with
security agencies and and with
scientists all over the world and it was
the first time she'd been to New York
City and she fell in love with it and
when I read this book initially I was in
Australia and when I moved to New York
City I felt the same way and I almost
carried her in my heart while I did and
so she had to take the subway in order
to get to a lot of her meetings and it
turned out that as she's riding the
subway because her mind was so true
over the last few months - listening for
signals within the noise that as she was
on the train she ended up missing all of
her meetings because she was listening
so intently for secret messages that she
didn't realize you know what was real
and what wasn't anymore
and so I found myself when I first
started taking the subway trying to
listen for messages in that - but then I
realized something about the difference
between myself and dr. Ally are awake
and that is that I kind of look for this
sort of stuff - which is how is similar
but dr. Arroway didn't have JavaScript
so what if dr. Arroway did have
JavaScript you know how could she try
and visualize the hidden messages in the
sort of noises that she falls in love
with so I found myself asking what does
sound look like and you know how can we
visualize that so we saw some of that
last night where the sounds were
visualized long like the the frequency
samples I'm gonna do something slightly
different today and we're gonna find out
via art what sound can be made to look
like so we're gonna use the Web Audio
API and before I go into this you're
probably wondering what the formulaic
spectrum is well that's a made-up word
so I'll explain so when you work with
data especially in your professional job
you want to make sure that that the
integrity of that data is is accurate
and the way that you're presenting that
data is also super accurate and so when
you're creating art be loyal to that the
data is really important in order to
create beauty that people can still
relate back to the data right so that's
really really important
when you start getting on the data
corruption side things start to get
messy there's a slight disconnect and
you're not really sure what's going on
but the thing is like that's art - like
who cares it's it's not it's not
important because you start with
something and you come up with something
unexpected at the other end so the talk
today is sort of focusing more
it's this messy side just to give you a
bit of an indication so the way that I
wanted to use the Web Audio API was I
wanted to record samples of the subway
and then I wanted to analyze that PCM
data so what is PCM it stands for pulse
code modulation so it's actually the raw
uncompressed audio data so it's the
samples that have been taken from the
analog world and then digitized so each
value in like a PCM file the the sample
ranges from negative 1 to positive 1 in
value so that's really important cuz
we're sort of going to map to that later
and some common PCM format file
extensions WAV files a files a ul 16 and
of course start PCM and this is a rather
wonky photo I took from Wikipedia that
sort of shows how you have your analog
sine waves and then you do math to
figure out like how to actually sample
that at regulate intervals so they're
the sort of values that we'll be playing
with now I end a lot of time sort of
secretly trying to record sounds on the
subway and I decided to pick a really
annoying obnoxious sound that we've all
sort of learned to ignore so if you've
never been on the New York City subway
before you may not be familiar with this
so I'll play it for you those who have
will be very annoyingly aware of it
stand clear of the closing doors please
and that dingdong at the end every time
okay so what if we took this sounds
right what if we took it as a WAV file
and open debt and looked at the data and
what if we took all of those values from
negative one to positive one and we said
okay each sample is a pixel on our
screen and then what if we took that
range and just mapped it over so it
would be zero to 255 to make it easier
for us to work with right negative one
to positive one is a really weird range
to work with unless you're working with
random numbers and what if that new
value that we've mapped it to would
affect the hue of the pixel that we're
putting on the page so I won't freak you
all out with too much code this morning
given that we were all drinking the
night before but it takes you know 12 to
13 lines of code in order to achieve
this a lot of art is just a bunch of for
loops and I was telling someone this
last night you're just taking data and
then looping around and doing crazy
things with it within the loop so we use
the audio context to decode the audio
data and we're just feeding in like
what's a coda and array buffer and then
once we've decoded that within the
promise we can get one of the channels
so we're just getting the left ear
because it's art it doesn't matter for
dropping the right ear we loop through
that and once we've mapped the value
from 2 to from 0 to 255 we can then
generate a pixel out of it by generating
a hue saturation luminosity converting
it to RGB and then we can manipulate a
image data canvas object and then put
that back onto the canvas in that very
last line so these slides will be up
online later so you can have a look at
that more closely if you like so what
does it look like if we just do this
well this is sort of what we have and so
that comes out really interesting I
actually thought it was really beautiful
and so there's a lot of pixels in there
but you can sort of see this rainbow
banding effect which i think is really
really cool
and if you're so if you've really been
paying attention this photo in the last
10 seconds you
realize that you can actually see the
patterns of the sound and this really
delighted me a lot you can actually make
out the individual words through those
bands at the top so you can actually
figure out based on how big the bands
are which word and syllable the speaker
was saying then you can see this big
empty bit but that's the white noise and
then they very obnoxious dingdong at the
end is in like vibrant rainbow colors
and I thought this was actually really
cool like this was proof that the the
dotted integrity is like one for one you
can actually see it and so that's really
cool to verify that that you know you've
brought that in and visualized it
there's only one problem with that that
picture that you just looked at is
300,000 pixels and a couple of times I
got the code wrong and I just completely
crashed the browser because it got stuck
trying to work on something you can't
console.log within that loop or it will
freeze for example and when you think
about it I just got the one channel I
didn't get the other ear so imagine if
you had that would be 600,000 so it's
it's just it's a lot to work with and
it's a little bit scary so this is this
is a bit of a problem like how do we
sort of like reduce that I thought maybe
the best way that to reduce that is to
map it audio to visuals and then back
out to audio again what if we can make
different audio out of this so what if
we took the simple concepts of a song
right it's 16 beats so how do we sort of
divide that up well theoretically we
could take the three hundred and eight
thousand seven hundred and twenty eight
samples and we could divide that by
sixteen beats right so now we have our
chunks of samples to do something with
but that's still a lot of samples that's
19 thousand samples so what if we sort
of start getting real with the data
corruption and start losing data and
what if we average the sample values of
each beat so essentially we add all of
them together divide it by 19,000 and
then we end up with a negative 1 to
positive 1 range like value for every
single beat then we can take that value
and do something sort of meaningful with
it but it's it's a lot simpler to work
with so what if we wanted to put people
back on the train
we might be able to designate the seat
color of each feet based on the value
and maybe that seat color denotes what
drumbeats or what oscillator note we're
gonna play and then this little kitty at
the bottom what if if he was sitting on
a seat that was you know designated by a
specific value as well within that range
what if he could do a guitar strum and a
note to sort of accompany that
so what we get is something like this so
there are eight seats on the left and
eight seats on the right so that makes
up sixteen beats and you can see here
the cat has appeared in in this sort of
pattern now this is taking the direct
data from the the PCM values again from
that stand clear of the closing doors
please sound so without further ado
let's have a listen to what that sounds
like
okay so you get the point not sure
whether that's thank you so that's very
strange music and I sort of thought what
if we could make this a little more
entertaining so I have a friend and his
name is Mark Johnson and you can tell he
lives in New York just by looking at him
partly and he's a very incredibly
talented designer and he's also just a
really funny guy so I I met up with him
in the cafe a couple of weeks ago and I
said you don't happen to have any silly
sample sounds that you've recorded of
your own voice to you and without
surprise I said actually I do and he
just dropped boxed me a bunch of samples
so what happens if we put mark into this
train you know what is this gonna sound
like let's let's have a listen
anyway that's sort of a little bit
funnier and he we hasn't seen this yet
so I guess I'll just send him this video
okay so a little bit about how I put
this piece of art together
most of it is SVG images that I've drawn
in a different program and imported them
in just as image tags it's a lot of divs
so those seats are just floating divs
next to each other right so this this
sort of application is way easy to deal
with in canvas in my last example
because you're just working with CSS and
you're working with JavaScript
manipulating those Dom elements so I
highly recommend doing art with divs and
things like that because you probably
couldn't tell by looking at it that it
was just straight markup that you can
look at in in the chrome developer tools
and then I'm using CSS animations for
that cursor to move across and I'm also
doing CSS animations the the cats kind
of danced along with this drama as well
and yeah obviously I'm not a musician
because that didn't sound great but I'm
hoping to sort of improve this music and
I've been talking to some of my musical
colleagues and they've been helping me
out but I'm better at Hardware things
and I think I'm better than earn for
that so I thought okay what would
playing this music look like in the real
world like can I do something to do with
hardware that can transfer this really
weird composition in the browser and
then we can play it back out in the real
world again
so I attend this meet up in New York
City code JavaScript as a code Brooklyn
Deus and they have this really funny
riff on the MTA metro card that you use
in the train system so it just says
brooklyn javascript this is what the
actual card looks like so you can see
it's actually really clever and that's
how ticket to get in and it's also our
drink ticket to get a free drink or you
can keep it and you have a souvenir and
i thought to myself that's that's such a
clever like riff to do on it like could
i do my own riff so i decided to lay out
a custom printed
afford and I thought what if I put a
speaker on the circuit board and then we
can play the sound but making it look
like a metric HUD so what it makes it
obvious what sort of sounds it's going
to play in the first place so that's the
tie back so this is what it looks like I
I think if they turn the video on I
actually have it here so if you wanted
to come and find me later on that's
that's it there with the giant this is
like a little 3d printed house for a
speaker that I stole from a musical
greeting card and you can program the
chip on the board as well using the
headers in the corner here and it just
plays music off an SD card so if you can
put that composition on an SD card it
will work and I think it'll be a little
too quiet for me too I don't think you
can hear it but come and find me later
so here's a quick video of me testing it
out for the first time after it's
soldered it all together
I don't think you can hear it I'm sorry
the audio is gone but you hold the
button down and it plays the sound while
the the button is held down so this is
also using an 80 mega 328p so you've if
you've ever played with an Arduino
before I actually just like rips the
micro micro controller off the Arduino
and then just put my own custom code on
it so so you know this isn't quite
finished yet and I feel like there's not
enough JavaScript in it for for me to
say it's a JavaScript project so I
actually wrote something last year code
a viago which uses nodejs to flesh
compiled programs onto micro electronics
so I've actually already done that so I
did write the program that runs on this
in C++ but it uses JavaScript to flash
it on there so that's pretty cool the
next thing I want to do is to stream the
resulting song over USB connection with
node.js using WebSockets and it will
stream it over to the SD card and save
it as a file so I started working on
that a couple of nights ago during the
conference and I'm sort of almost there
but I have some weird SPI bottleneck
issues so I will blog about that soon if
I manage to get it up and going and of
course I I want to make better music you
know not very good at it but we'll
figure it out okay so things got a
little bit weird but you know it's ah
this is the point this is this is what
I'm trying to tell you you don't always
have to use your code for professional
use you know when I work on my job
everyday I want my code to look perfect
I wanted to be readable I wanted to be
performant but whenever I go home for
the day I almost want to rebel against
that and and be the little girl with the
Commodore 64 again and so this is why
I'm up here today because I want to go
over like what what was the point of
this so creative coding gets you out of
your comfort zone when you're not used
to using divs for things like music and
moving curses and and things like that
it teaches you how to think about the
tools you use everyday in a different
way and how you can sort of exploit that
kind of thing
art doesn't care about your semicolon
feelings so if you create really messy
code with unused variables
you know missing stuff all over the
place and and lots of repeated sort of
copied and pasted functions odd doesn't
care it's still going to show you what
you wanted to look at in the end and so
you can really have a play ignore the
actual code and just expressively start
writing because odd doesn't care about
perfection it's it's about exploration
so kill MC or Killian McMahon is a he's
a colleague and very close friend of
mine and one day during a hackathon at
work I said ki just teach me about music
and so this is him attempting to teach
me about chords like G major and C major
and he also told me about like staying
within those chords and creating really
cool sort of repeated loops so I'm
really hoping to apply that new
knowledge to this music and help it
evolve but I've never worked with
Killian in this way before
he's a designer and he writes the HTML
and CSS and then I write the JavaScript
that accompanies his work and that's how
we normally collaborate but this offered
this new sort of collaboration given
that he plays amazing music outside of
outside of work and if anyone's going to
Pike on this year in Portland he's
actually going to be opening and putting
in a band playing and it's a really
awesome band they called The Adventure
where they called the venture
capitalists and they make fun of the
startup scene and they're really really
cool so definitely check the route so I
guess what I'm saying is that odd is
about what you learned it's not about
it's not about the normal things that
that we care about when we talk about
syntax so take some time if you have the
privilege of spare time and write some
messy code and make lots of mistakes and
don't necessarily go back and fix them
you deserve a break from being judged
we're always riding on each other's code
reviews and we're always like
painstakingly going over line by line of
code but what if you could just type
like this you know it just it feels
soothing it feels expressive you're just
throwing stuff out there to see what
happens I had no idea that a train with
cat sitting on it playing guitars it was
going to come out of this project but
that's that's what happened so code like
no one's watching
I want you to remember that code like no
one's watching and if you can don't get
rebase before you push it up so I'm
starting to see an alarming problem in
our industry we're juniors look up to
programmers who are mid-level and senior
and lead and they see us writing this
perfect code out of the gate because
they see it after we've opened the pull
request
well they join a company and they look
at our finished code that's already
sitting in production and I see juniors
even in my job just frozen looking at
this empty text file when they starting
a feature and it's it's that fear of the
blank canvas they think that they have
to write everything perfectly and have
all the details in their head the first
time and that's just not true
that's not how any of us write I don't
think we write something sort of good
and then we write it Gouda and then we
write it the goodest right that's that's
how it works and having to explain that
and having to get those genius to come
and pay with me whenever I've started
something so they can see my process
that shouldn't be necessary we we should
be showing people history even an
hour.get so they can see that we wrote
something messy and then we went back
and we thought about it and and we
changed it in ways that we wouldn't have
seen when we first started so just get
push and the scariest thing I've ever
done last night was I pushed all of the
art that I showed you today I pushed it
all up to github and I left it learn you
know there's multiple audio contexts
going on and they all have slightly
different ways of naming the variables
and it's a complete mess but I'm
inviting you to look at it so you can
see how stuff evolved and it doesn't
matter because all I wanted people to
see was the final product and it works
perfectly fine so think about that in
your everyday so that we can all be
learning more of each other and not
being so terrified of having to be
perfect the first time so that we can
make it okay for others so if you take
anything away today I want you to make
some art and want you to just throw it
away if you don't like it because it's
just code you can write more
so if you'd like to have a look at my
art examples you can go to that address
and the repo will also go there so that
you can have a look at the code if you
like il TSW just stands for I love the
subway that's my secret I I ride the
subway even when I'm not going anywhere
sometimes because I love it so I was
trying to make everyone else love this
subway today and if you'd like to go
through my slides again so look at some
of the code samples or just like play
with the stuff that I showed you can go
to again new cut github today you
slashed formulaic spectrum I just got a
jackal build error in my email so I will
try and fix it it's not quite up yet and
I will be blogging about this project
really soon to show how I made the
electronics and and sort of why I wanted
to do this weird everything in the first
place so keep an eye out for that I'm a
pretty regular blogger and thank you